Alright, now that we have our editor ready to work with Groom assets and everything's
been restarted, let's talk about importing Groom assets.
But before we do that, I just want to reiterate on the Groom creation workflow as understanding
this is pretty critical to having a successful experience with Groom inside of Unreal Engine
5.
So first off, we create our Groom, the initial creation and styling and things
like that inside of our digital content creation.
And we can do this using something like XGen within Maya, Yeti, Shave, or Haircut, or even
Houdini.
Any type of tool that will allow you to create hair utilizing splines can be used
to generate hair for Groom inside of Unreal Engine 5.
Now once we're done and we're ready to export that hair, what we do is we take
that Groom asset or that asset inside of our DCC, and we export it using the Alembic or
the .abc file format.
Once we have that into the Alembic file format, we can then import that to Unreal
Engine 5.
At that point, Unreal Engine 5 will then be able to adjust the Groom data.
We can on import either decimate that data a little bit, get rid of some of the data
to make it more performant.
We can also create and adjust materials.
We can create and adjust the physics that is applied to the Groom, as well as attach
the Groom to a skeletal mesh so that it will follow a character around and interact
as the character moves throughout the world.
So again, remember, we start and style our hair inside of our DCC.
And then once we're done, we can export that to an Alembic file or .abc file and
then bring that into Unreal to adjust all of its visual and physics parameters.
Now when you do import something, it's very, very simple.
All we have to do is just grab our Alembic file and then drag and drop it into the
folder or wherever we want inside of the content browser.
Now when we do do that, we will be presented with the Groom Import Options box here.
And inside of here, we can do a number of different things.
We can adjust the rotation or the scale.
And if we look at our groups here, we even have the ability to do things like adjust
the interpolation quality or the interpolation distance will actually reduce the complexity
of our Groom.
So let's just pop over to Unreal and take a look at how we do this now.
So here is the 5.6 third person template.
And then I'm going to bring up my folder here that's got my shared Groom assets in
it.
And then all I'm going to do is just drag this M Hair Body Curly, or I should say
Bob Curly right in here.
And there we go.
We have our Groom Import Options.
As you can see here, by default, it's probably going to look something like this.
And if we go to our groups and expand, you can see here, we have our interpolation
quality and our interpolation distance.
And again, if we adjust these, we can make our Groom a little bit more compact, a little
bit more optimized.
I already know that this is fine just the way it is.
So I'm just going to hit Import.
And once I do that, there is my Groom asset, and I can open it up.
And when I do, it's going to open it up right inside of the Groom Asset Editor.
Now in the next part of this video tutorial series, what we're going to do is actually
go over what each one of these little tabs does inside of the Groom Editor in relation
to our Groom.
So don't worry, we're going to be covering all of that in the next video.
So again, let's just recap what we did to get to this point.
So all we've really done is we have taken the file here, this m, our hair, mbobcurly.abc,
and just dragged and dropped that right into the editor here.
And once we've done that, we'll be ready for the next part of our video, which is
going to be exploring each of the Groom tool settings.